kyle gibson on the short end of the
stick and his opening day start
lasting just one out he knows what he's
got to do to improve
well he's ready to go and the first
pitch of the ball game is
hit hard but foul or no
there a while and well it might have
been foul but dahl got it either way it
was right
on the line that is a fair ball shag one
pitch one out
was owen five with a 585 era here and he
gets a strike out of biggio
for the second out of the inning he's
one
two swings and misses strike three
gibson sharp in his half of the first
inning and the rangers back
ready to go to work well not everybody
has an ace but the boujee certainly have
one in
yunjin ryu he's been terrific in his
year plus with the blue jays
the 2-2 and right over the inside corner
and no
argument from kiner falefa one down way
out in front of a doll no balls two
strikes
and he got him to chase a cutter away
and ryu is off to a great start today
with back-to-back strikeouts ryu in a
groove in the early going it looks like
2-2 got him to chase a slow curve
and what a start to the afternoon for
the big lefty as he strikes out the side
in the bottom of the first
there's a swing and a miss guriel
strikes out
two away gibson already with three
strikeouts
and you can make it four as he gets
grichik
two strikeouts per annie gibson looks a
whole lot better this afternoon
solac a 222 hitter he's batting cleanup
today
four for 18. no homer's in a run bad at
him
clean up today and he hammers this ball
down the left field line
gone a rocket down the line for solac
and the rangers starting to score this
afternoon it's one nothing
good to see nick solak join the party
chris woodward has talked about him
quite a bit
this week and some questions about the
swing and where he was and he said
no matter what's going on with nick
solak even if he's in a little bit
of a funk he is still going to give you
a battle he's still going to put
good swings on the basement
a swing by trevino ground ball deep
short nice sliding stop by semi and gets
up and throws low
and guerrero can't dig it out guerrero
is still learning how to play for his
base
[Applause]
leyote is one for 16. he's up there from
the right side
so two gone and this one out to right
field a broken back single
around third base trevino no throw
offered
from hernandez who led the league in
outfield assists last year
but didn't even bother and the rangers
go up two-nothing
[Applause]
this one out to center field base hit
for culverson
his first hit as a ranger into third
base is tavares
and the beat goes on good start to this
game for the bottom of the order
first and third two down and the 01 hit
sharply to short diving catch by simeon
on a liner to his right a really nice
play by marcus simeon to save a run
swinging a miss he strikes out jansen
his fifth strikeout of the afternoon
are you shaking off jansen a couple of
times now has the sign he wants and he
got him with a cutter away
as you said buck that's where he wanted
it on the previous pitch
and he placed it perfectly there to
strike him out
2-2 there's a swing and a miss another
strikeout
for gibson is seventh pardon me sixth of
the day
more of a chase changeup good speed
differential there at 85 miles an hour
but
a little bit of depth below the zone and
hernandez can't lay off
he waves and misses another strikeout
seven for gibson
one two to jansen a ground ball that
gets through
culberson and down the line into foul
territory
around a third on the play comes panic
and
jansen's at second uh danny jackson hit
that ball really
hard at this point kyle gibson's got
some work to do here
and a hard drive up the middle and he
might get two
kind of left for the first in time and a
huge double play to get him out of the
jam
[Applause]
and a cutter right at the knees for
strike three call
tavares shaking his head and saying no
no no he's in disbelief as he walks back
to the first base dugout
hits it sharply but lined right to panic
out at second a nice play
by joe panic and that'll be that five in
the books
look good strike three called eighth
strikeout
for gibson and another slider here from
kyle gibson all the talk about the
cutter and it seems like the slider has
been the better pitch
for him today so well located 84 miles
an hour you're just not going to put in
a better spot than that
1-2 swing and a miss and ryu gets him
a 1-2-3 bottom of the sixth two-nothing
rangers going top seven and spores is on
for the
third time made two appearances in the
series in kansas city
bouncer down to culberson at third base
scores
three ground ball outs on seven pitches
that'll do
stretch time in arlington
[Music]
um slightly right center i guess
this one up the middle and simeon can't
hold on to it
trevino is on to start the bottom of the
seventh inning
this one on the ground and that's
through base it into right field
trevino takes a little turn but doesn't
look like he ever
had in mind going to third base
back-to-back singles
nice bunk on the first base line
everybody's safe now they're going to
want to appeal
guerrero went to third base to see if
they could get trevino
and he fired a strike over there but
jose
looked like he got in
that's a tough review now i definitely
won charlie montoya
wanted to challenge it makes sense
especially at this juncture at the end
that becomes a
that's a really big play right here i
think that's how they scored
let's see maybe a move point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so now very simple it's just a fielder's
choice
and it goes 3-5 to put out at third base
were you not a huge strikeout guy
they are not going and it is swung on
and missed where you
get some two down simeon has flied out
singled and walked 3-1
and simeon lifts it to left field and
deep it is
gone second deck for simeon his third
home run of the season already
and it's two to one second home run of
the series for marcus simeon
and that is his 18th career home run
against texas
1-2 to beshette got a piece of it a
little roller swinging bunt up the third
baseline
and he's got himself an infield hit
throw gets past low but bounces back off
the fence so beau will
stay at first oh shoot me gurion
in the air short left field so he was
going after the three old pitch gaul
tucks it away
bottom of the eighth coming up bush gets
out of any further trouble it's two to
one
sets and fires and panic shoots it the
other way
into left field for a base hit
davis running and a swing and a miss
strike three
kennedy slams the door and the rangers
back to 500 with a 2-1 win over toronto